[Music]
bills i'm reluctant to put on my
headphones
why is that done because i think i'm i
have debonair hair
you do have good hair i'll put it on
just to just get quite a height
it is it's a bouffant how many inches
would you say
um i think it's probably two and a half
inches high easy
but once i put my headphones on it's
going to collapse a little bit
but can i talk you through what i did
yeah
i washed it right that's a good idea
shampoo conditioner
lovely out of the shower i combed it all
the way back and i let it dry like that
now it looked terrible
no it won't no it did when it dried it
looked terrible it looked like
arthur fonzarelli type vibes but then
what i did was i got some sandy kind of
waxy stuff
and i pushed it all forward or forward
or forward or back
and this is what we got so it started
back after the shower yeah
then forward forward aggressively
forward aggressively photographers
before back
and then this is it it's brilliant but
now what we're gonna have is we're gonna
have a little
step in the middle that's all right
don't worry about it this is not a
podcast about debonair hair
as long as you don't bend down you would
never notice yeah good point
um so i went to see you last weekend
yeah i remember i was there left some
maltesers in your fridge
ate them yesterday i was gonna say did
you bring them
no my son ate them and i showed them how
to do the malteser trick
oh yeah you go at that anyone who's
never had a malteser or anyone listening
like that means lie down on the floor
yeah if if you're just listening
i'm laying back and then i put a
malteser on my lips
and i seal my lips around it then i blow
up
so that the malteser is basically
floating
in air yeah it's like a little miniature
planet like a chocolate planet
yeah that i'm keeping up there only
through the power of my lungs
yeah and then i'll let my lungs stop
so the air stops yeah oh my mouth and it
goes yeah but don't inhale the malteser
because you don't want in a malteser in
your lung because you can get a very
serious disease
malt lungs it's called a lot of people
die that way yeah yeah
it's like 20 or 30 people a year die
from doing that so
let us know if you guys can do the
malteser trick because it's not easy
it's not easy and if anyone can do three
in a row
you've won the world record but when i
was driving here today i was very
excited i thought great i get a chance
to see bill
he's gonna bring me the maltesers that
are left in his fridge at the weekend i
went over to see
billy i brought his wife her favorite
crisps two packets of skips
i brought billy a bar of nuggets which i
ate the next morning some people call it
nougat that's a controversial thing
it's pink and it's weight yeah it's
lovely nugget
scott knutson i brought some crisps
i brought a crunchy and then when i left
i left some maltesers in the fridge oh
is that your maltesers those were mine
but oh did you think they were for jack
i thought no i just thought they were a
gift for the family well they were they
were you were
um should we do a quick update as to
where we're at with um
elijah playing league of of legends
update elijah gate
so on a scale of one to uh fruit size of
fruit
being a great no the the the tiny seeds
in a strawberry yes
bad what was top the top was a
watermelon where are we at this week
with elijah playing league of legends
with us
what would still not even reach the size
of an apple i think we've got worse
i've never spoken to him since he came
in here that day week one
was a a grape slowly rotting in the sun
i think we're now at raisin because i've
i've texted elijah a little bit
since our podcast and he's kind of
avoided
mentioning league of legends we had a
game last night that way two games
how did we get on well dr mundo who is
one of my favorite i'll go in the jungle
with dr mundo energy he's been a jungler
for a while dr mundo but they've made
him a top laner
and i got destroyed have you ever played
top lane before i've never been up i've
never even went to the top lane before
and the top lane is the longest lane in
league of legends and that's where all
the
big tanks and bruises hang out and
that's where my son plays right
so you take a bunch of damage yeah
because the lane is so long that you
need to
take on that damage yeah unfortunately
you got
battered totally bad and i didn't know
what the buttons did
and i was weeping yeah no it was but
also i thought you were very unlucky
because you were against
a why one or a yonei as they call them
in
league of legends we call him y1 who is
not he's not
normally a top laner he's usually mid
lane and he's fast and aggressive
and scary yeah he can kind of like
shape-shift with his sword and like
you know dig at your guts and who was
the second person i played against
allowy
i didn't like them at all but do you
yeah this made me laugh a lot do you
remember me saying to you
just get the tentacles don't get their
tentacles because what happens with
allowing she's kind of a
like a polynesian hawaiian type vibe
lovely do you think she's is it female
or male i think i have no idea we're not
sure about the sex
if you could let us know about the sex
of a lowie we'd appreciate it
what she does is she puts tentacles down
around her not she doesn't control it it
just happens a tentacle hits a wall a
tentacle it's a wall
if you attack allowing her tentacles
will hit you but if you just attack the
tentacles they won't hit you
so what you have to do is hit the
tentacles before you go after allowing
but what if allah is there
that's all right if well she's attacking
you
well me to be honest so i would stand as
far back as you can from malawi and the
tentacles and from a distance
yeah try and fl throw a cleaver because
you're a doctor
yeah throw a cleaver at the tentacles
i'm to have another goal when i get in
today
it's it can be extremely demoralizing
um but when it's good it's good when you
play
without me do you win more games
a very seldom play with like i never go
on and play myself
really yeah there's a couple of times i
went on just with jack my son
yeah and we've played a couple of games
but pretty much
i've only ever played with you and nigel
right right
i play much less on my own than i used
to but when i learn a new character
i try and get him to the point where i
know what i'm doing yeah you don't want
to come on embarrass yourself in front
of all of us i think is what we all did
last night
phil's one of our sponsors is liquid iv
and you
love liquid eye veda i've really started
to love
liquid iv dom they have a lot of flavors
is the one that's at the top of your
list currently
i've got a few actually just now i've
just started to get into strawberry
it used to be watermelon ah watermelon
is my favorite i like lemon lime if you
want to do a swap we could maybe do some
swaps because you have a ton of flavors
right lots of flavors my wife's favorite
is guava
i just love it i think i mean i just
feel like i'm doing myself some good
before i do something say for instance
i'm doing uh
a bike ride i know i'm going to do a
long bike ride i get a liquid iv
nice watermelon yeah and i drink that
before i start
yeah i think it's probably good
pre-workout and post-workout
and just to kind of knock the cobwebs
off i mean it contains
five essential vitamins more vitamin c
than an
orange and as much potassium as a banana
and of course it's going to be a lot
healthier than your sugary sports drinks
no artificial flavors or preservatives
and it's got less sugar
than an apple amazing so grab your
liquid iv
in bulk nationwide at costco and you can
get 25
off when you go to liquidity.com and use
the code onion
at checkout that's 25 off anything you
order when you get better hydration
today using the promo code
onion at liquidive.com
you know what i like to eat in the
morning dom is it cereal it is it's
magic spoon isn't it magic spoon cereal
i like magic spoon too because it's good
tasty
healthy cereal because i'm trying to get
healthier huh
and people say cereal too much sugar but
then comes magic spoon changes the game
yeah it's zero grams of sugar 13 to 14
grams of protein and only four net grams
of carbs in each serving
and only 140 calories are serving listen
to this it's keto friendly gluten-free
grain free soy free low-carb and gmo
free wow and so many nice
nice flavors cocoa fruity frosted peanut
butter
you've done the peanut butter cocoa
combination love it dumb
so tasty so go to magicspoon.com
onion to grab a variety pack and try it
today and be sure to use our promo code
onion
at checkout to save five dollars off
your order and magic spoon is so
confident in the product it's backed
with a hundred percent happiness
guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money
no questions asked remember get your
next delicious bowl of guilt-free cereal
at magicspoon.com
onion and use the code onion to save
five dollars off
thank you magic spin for sponsoring this
episode it's time for
i will take the ring um
well should we jump into these questions
come on no no questions i think we're
doing a quiz
first [ __ ] was well you know what that
means dom what
before a quiz there's always a song oh
come on let's sing a song
hold on a second billy is just jumping
to his
left to get a guitar and now he jumped
back
like a sprite to his right hold on dom
now holding a guitar wonderful
lovely deep rich trickly mahogany
is there a mahogany who makes that
guitar we're not advertising it's martin
who don't who don't um given to the show
but by god they make good kids they've
given you the gift of music
yeah enough that's enough dom i think
you know this song now i'm going to sing
harmonies oh
that would be like uh like art garfunkel
shall we start on the third time around
yeah come on
here it goes here we go
do you know the answers to the questions
that we'll ask
do you know the answers
do you know the answers to the questions
that we'll ask
do you know the answers will you
take the ring
i did a very professional thing what did
you do there as i did the last
bit of the harmony on the ring i moved
it further
away and then back oh that was bright
yeah frank sinatra
he was the king of that sinatra you know
frank sinatra yeah it was a guy who knew
him
yeah is it what he was the king of
bringing the microwave oh
yes i think adele said a really funny
thing once where she said when i'm in
concert and i know i'm not going to be
able to reach that high note because
i've been
singing for the last few months yeah i
just give the mic over to the audience
and say sing it with me come on so you
can save your voice that's a good idea
isn't it yeah hold on i'm going to put
the guitar away billy
is now moving to his left and
almost dropped the guitar and now he's
back guys oh wow we have humans on uh
on the tv here hello adam and hello
david hi uh
how's it going guys now where where are
adam and david from
not only geographically in northeastern
pennsylvania
pennsylvania have you ever been not sure
where is that
it's somewhere in the united states okay
it's one of the states it's one of the
54.
uh adam what's pennsylvania the most
famous for
oh that's probably a good question it is
i live
not famous for but little known fact is
hbo
was founded and not too far from where i
live
and david where are you in this world
that we live in
well i'm australian but i live right
down the road from
dom's old hunting grounds i'm in
birmingham
oh you're riding home right now nice
from
birmingham and where in australia were
you from before that
brisbane the best city in australia
maybe brizzy i do like brisbane crazy
busy i had a lot of fun in brisbane yeah
brisbane's great
love brisbane sydney and melbourne those
are my three favorites
yeah well should we get to these
questions so you guys have got
five questions for rosa thing and we've
got five
very hard now should we say where
adam and david are from not
geographically
but why they are here on our quiz yes we
should and i think you should do that
because it slipped my mind
fell out of my brain you don't actually
know i'll i'll leave it to adam and
david they'll tell us
why are you guys on here and why do you
know stuff about
tolkien that's a good one
well adam and i are the moderators of
the
lord of the rings subreddit and that's
where you guys
came to join us for your amazing
ama so we we run the place and we sweep
the floors and we keep it nice and clean
i love it so they guys they're from the
reddit the subreddit
and is that quite a healthy uh reddit is
it is there a lot of um
chat going on there is it quite a
positive place to be
uh yeah um
i was actually see if we were prepared
these are things that i'd have
on hand but we've got how many
subscribers
a billion half a million wow
one thousand wow well could you tell
everybody
listen their friendship onion please
yeah
i think we do actually post every yeah
we pin every
episode that goes good good brilliant
brilliant
yeah well it's time for the quiz
it's time for the quiz what are the
rules are the quiz bills
questions and answers but we're so we're
a team we're a team
marion pippen team team shire
team shire lovely stuff do you guys have
a team name
uh you can pick that one adam oh oh
should we just be like team l-o-t-r or
slash r slash l-o-t-r
okay right subreddit
we're gonna ask five questions adam and
david are gonna ask five questions and
if it goes to a tie breaker we have a
tie breaker situational question
for you i think we're going to do quite
well here tom
right do you guys want to start or
should we start
oh it's your show i feel like you guys
should start off adam is so polite
yeah you start though question one
the misty mountains were once inhabited
by a rambunctious clan known as durian's
folk
what are durian's folk most commonly
known as
you have four multiple choices
are we doing multiple choices yeah we
are right i think this is very easy but
we started tomorrow so yeah we don't
know i got too difficult
uh what are uh durians folk most
commonly known as a
dwarves b ants c hobbits
d elves
what do you think adam's pretty easy one
that is a pretty easy one
all right a warm up you know yep
yep and the answer is probably
dwarfs is the correct
answer jojo is too easy
go on give us one give us one adam come
on david
i'll keep school you go mate yep
okay see i thought maybe i made mine too
tricky we'll see oh no um
although mine were heavily book focused
i felt like a peak nerd
but we've read the books we've read the
books
my heart is pumping i i did watch the
healthiest episodes where you said you
had read the books
we have yeah yeah go on i knew that was
in there um
so let's go with in 19 rings of power
were made by
the elves in the second age correct and
sauron took from them
16. three of them the three that keller
brimbler made alone that sauron never
touched remained hidden and in the third
age they're still wielded by
three people do you know who those three
people
are billy i think we've been and i guess
this should be worth
three hidden rings we're just gonna
confer amongst ourselves adam and david
i think i know where one is where is it
well did one was one
up bill the pony's ass no is that not an
around that wasn't a ring now um
i mean i mean did you know there was
three rings
i hadn't i thought we were doing lord
the flies questions
no were you reading the wrong book yeah
yeah this could get
so i was gonna say right something about
piggy or ralph
now so in the third age these three
there's eleven kings seven for the dwarf
nine for mortal men
one in a ditch covered in [ __ ]
one in a fire like a fire pit
yeah to a paponi's ass no that's four
rings i've missed
right so there's three let's have a
guess do we think one's
like in the in the dwarven in moriah
no that's not right is it because we
went tomorrow there wasn't a ring
anywhere near it
i had to look we have to guess right
okay one in the sky
well one of the wizards has probably got
one
rather guest no he's not going he's
there
should we just say we don't know yeah i
think we should say
well it is it is people not places it's
people
people have them people actually have
people have them
so and it's is it give us a clue give us
a clue
like because it's the it's the you guys
were on the right track with the nine
nine for men seven yeah dwarves and
three for the elves three for the elves
and those three are
still around and being used in this
dozen galadriel
has got one she's got a lovely one yeah
she's got
one of the nicest feminine looking ones
now does what about um
the guy from the matrix um mr
jones live tyler's dad yeah love tyler's
dad's got it
does he have one yeah he what's his name
again king of the elves
come on dom
no uh darwin's dad
what's the king of the elves called
again
elrond but that's right i'll give you
that one okay
elrond and sydney legolas is dad
keller born is that his name what's his
name no it's legolas his dad got one no
of course he's not i think we've only
got two i think we have to move i think
no one of the elves won't give us
another elf
but he's a high king
we got two yeah give us another hand
come on all right you've been too kind
third person that currently holds this
ring
isn't an elf hasn't an elf well it's at
he was with you for half the movie yeah
remember
that's true scandal for then isn't it no
he was after the movie half the month
for half
right oh i don't know how the minutes
work out it might be more than happy
aragorn
is it get out is it no i think we have
to move on is it i got two out of three
aragon's got an ice rink gandalf it was
goosey goosey
i said goose i think we don't can we get
should we get like half of it we get
half a point
because we we really really dug
ourselves out of three so i think that's
two points right
well that and i did say that was a
tricky one so it can't be two hours no
it can't be because
you won't
i was going to give you multiple choice
for this one but i'm not going anymore
these guys are too good i mean yeah
what is the name of thorin's sword
in the hobbit his sword
thorin do not give them multiple choices
no no don't
because they'll get it they'll get it
they'll definitely get it and you're on
a timer by the way
yeah we've already been here for half an
hour
what is the name the sword they find in
the troll cave right dave
that's the one i know both of them oh
gosh
oh all right well they find um glam
drink which gandalf takes
sting which bilbo takes and then orchest
which is the one that thorin keeps for
himself we've made it we've made it too
easy dog
you've got it you've got it right again
john
you said they weren't experts they're
experts
they're not going to do a subreddit if
they're not experts so our illustrious
producer john
uh came up with these questions right
not only that i'm a hard one not only
that
no it's these guys not only that but he
also got one of the questions wrong dude
again
do not tell our listeners john's going
to say again all right sorry adam and
david give us the next come on ask us a
really hard one this time that the first
one was so easy
all right i've got a question i think
this one's gonna be
pretty easy all right so i'm gonna let
you guys off the hook a little bit
patronizing this now you're going to get
that question
anyway i'm just going to leave with it
okay all right what is the elvish word
for friend is it drego
is it dargo is it
melon is it strawberry
you know this one do either well mary
does this in the books
yeah but in the film it was frodo yes
big friend
yeah it's definitely not strawberry no
is it melon yeah
i think it's melon 100 let's go let's do
it
do it melon melon
well done we've done it
this is back in the race this is where
the tide turns give them a hard one
i'm telling you i think i don't know if
we have any
hard ones getting them a hard one tom
well i'll ask him question four
well they're very book based why don't
you ask them
a movie-based one i still think they're
gonna get right go on
okay i'm just gonna slightly
change the question but it's still still
the same answer
when is frodo's birthday
we could give you multiple choice if
you're struggling i don't think so don't
because i think they know that
david's got it they i i'm pretty sure
they have a party on this day yeah
when is frodo's birthday might have to
give this one to you david i
gotta say i don't know the exact date
for this one i know it is the same as
bilbo's yes
david knows that i can see it in his
eyes they had a joint birthday so that
they could uh you know save money on the
cake
yeah well i'm going to be perfectly
honest
i don't know he doesn't know this is
when we come back remember frodo's
birthday okay should we give you the
multiple choice and you can guess from
that of things we'll give them all
all right go on there is it that's a
good question
thank you thank you well done well done
john all is forgiven
is it september 30th
september 22nd august 13th
or february 24th those dates again
september 30th september 22nd
august 13th or february 24th
what do you think adam they look stumped
yeah absolutely
the september ones okay
i always lean towards september yeah
it's a good name for an album actually
leaning towards september but then there
were two september ones
there was and we'll give you them again
one was
the 30th or the 22nd
yeah i'm not sure good it's a 50 50
chance
that'll work we could go with the 22nd
let's give that one a try
it's the correct answer you gave them
too much stuff i'm sorry
but i like them like they're growing
they're nice people
nonetheless we need to win no good point
hello friends if someone relies on your
financial support whether it's a child
an aging parent or even a business
partner you need
life insurance and if you need life
insurance you should go to
policy genius policy genius makes it
easy to compare quotes from over a dozen
top
insurers all in one place why compare
you can save 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes
with policy genius you could save a
thousand three hundred or more per year
on life insurance
by using policy genius to compare
policies
so here's how it works if you want to
get started first head to
policygenius.com and within minutes you
can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need
and compare personalized quotes to find
your best price and when you're ready to
apply
the policy genius team will handle the
paperwork
and the scheduling all for free nice
policy genius doesn't add on extra fees
so head
to policygenius.com to get started right
away
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
come on give us another one come on adam
so what is it is it two two
yeah it's two each ish it's actually one
let's call it two each so this is one
and a half each
right go okay
do you wanna go again david or all i got
one more you go mate give us a really
hard one this is just
way too easy do you want a really hard
well
what have you done medium hard yeah yeah
this one um like an edam
it's tricky but you have a 50 50 shot
because it's true or false
oh yeah we'll either be right or wrong
then yeah good point bill go on
you could guess one each maybe does it
work like that
so after the story ends mary would go on
to earn several other honors in his life
including titles such as master of
buckland
and mary the magnificent yes and
eventually
both mary and pippin are buried
alongside aragorn
in gondor correct done
is that the question it's true yeah it's
true yes it's true oh it's definitely
true
it's true we know that to be true
mary the magnificent marry the
magnificent because of his
sterling work during the scouring of the
shire which you were also fantastic in
yeah but i never became pippa the
magnificent no
i think he became known as pippin the
drunk yeah
um pep in the pregnant which was unusual
uh yeah once i found out in new zealand
that mary
and pippin were buried alongside aragorn
i suggested to billy and vigo that maybe
the three of us should be buried
together do you remember
and i said yeah well viggo said
absolutely not yeah
i was i said yes but viggo's very
against
it yeah vigo vetoed it yeah yeah all
right bills is it you
it is yes so hard hard
hard built hard okay then adam
and david as you went to the end of the
story
we shall do the same lovely after the
war of the rings
how many children did sam and rosie have
i will say again how many children
did sam and rosie have yes and just as a
clue he was quite virile
and also they didn't own a television
set
[Laughter]
you've skipped a question bills but
we'll get back to that though no because
i i thought this was hard
adam i want to say six yeah it is quite
a high number
did you say sex or six
just wondering in your australian accent
that is how you have children
if you want six would you like um a
multiple choice on this
would you like a multiple choice i'll
give you four chances here
was it thirteen
six eight or twenty one
lovely stuff there bills lovely stuff
well six was in there and that was your
your first thought probably roll with
that right
yeah yeah let's go with six final
answers six and i have to say
it was thirteen kids he had
if we get this question right from adam
and david then we have one you better
make a difficult one
right hmm should i go for my most
difficult point yeah why
not why not i think so yeah it's only
hard if you don't know the answer yeah
right
well i'm i'm going to give you my most
difficult question but
i'm going to make this a question that
only
dom can because he knows you know it
i know yeah because i know he knows it
okay
okay so um because the question relates
directly to the character of pippin
okay so when pippin
sings for dennethor okay his
beautiful haunting song
chopping down tomatoes i'm welling up
right now what's
the first line of the song
you can have a hint or a multiple choice
if you want
don't give him it because i know for a
fact he has this played every evening
before he closes his eyes yeah it's the
song that i meditate too
so i know for a fact he's gonna get this
just i'm just seeing your lovely little
face here singing it
um i think i need a multiple choice
i think i don't know i because there's
so
much going on in that scene it's hard
just to concentrate on the lyrics
because of your
how's it going on what i was doing i
know you do that thing where you say
oh we'll fade fade but that's the end
but it's the start we need give us give
us some
multiple choice david right so billy
this is him saying he doesn't remember
this is
this is a disgrace i was very drunk when
i made those trilogy of films
right multiple choice one
mist and shadow cloud and shade mister
shadow
two all that is gold does not glitter
oh that is good okay
three home is behind the world ahead
[Music]
or oh you can search far and wide
i have to be extremely transparent with
you both here adam and david
nothing is ringing a bell it's almost as
if my brain has been taken out
and put on a shelf for a moment could
you could you read those again please
david
just just very good again just very i
love them again david because i
i feel like i've become drunk on your
words
mist and shadow cloud and shade that's
halfway through the song
all that is gold does not glitter it's
true home is behind
the world ahead what's that one
what you can search far and wide
i think have you any idea well it's
almost as if there was like a voice in
my mind that
i'm good i'm going to go for
secret home is behind the world ahead
because i can dominate
rather than it you've done it it's
easy one i knew you wouldn't let me down
dom
guys i plucked that out of nowhere
fantastic will you please listen to that
when you go home well that memory comes
back
yeah isn't it how well he knows my
performance
it's incredible guys what a quiz so we
bested
two of the lord rings experts on the
internet there
so i think we should invite more experts
because
we cannot be beaten yeah
we enjoyed that guys that was fantastic
thanks a lot guys thanks for playing
along if you ever want us back on your
reddit give us a shout we loved it it
was great fun on there the people were
cool
we really liked it thanks adam and david
have a wonderful rest of your day thanks
a lot guys
bye-bye bye right bills amazing quiz
oh it was quite difficult wasn't it it
was brilliant should we get into some
voicemails because let's do it from what
john said we've got a
backlog a ton let's do it
oh emails and real mails fastest tigers
slow
snails hi dom and billy this is dj
calling in from minnesota um and my
question
relates to something you've talked about
before
on the podcast but i don't think you've
ever been asked
so here goes who is your favorite beatle
first of all so dom who's your favorite
billy who's your favorite
and which beatles would you have liked
to play mary and pippin
in the theoretical lord of the rings
film
that was proposed that the beatles were
going to star in in the late 60s
so that's my question who was your
favorite beatle and which beatles
would you like to have played mary and
pippen
uh anyways thanks so much and i'm really
glad you're doing this podcast
you know we we could we could actually
show the audience here how well we know
each other by
answering the question for each other
because i think i know
who your favorite beatle is and for why
and i get the impression that you
probably know who
mine is and for why i think maybe i
might get yours wrong though but i said
have a go
should we try right go i'm gonna say
that your favorite beetle was george
harrison and the reason for that was
because
he went on quite a significant
spiritual journey in his life which you
identify with
i think i think you're absolutely right
yeah and i also feel like
he wrote some of the best songs very
difficult to choose
that's so hard and it changes every day
doesn't it yeah but if i had to choose
yours
i would say uh john lennon
i think because he was the most
sort of he he
he plowed his own road he if he believed
in something he went
completely to that nth degree
and i feel like you you like that that's
totally right
that's right we're very good at each
other john lennon just to touch upon
that for a second because john lennon
has
had a lot of flaws to his personality
things that i'm sure he
apologized through out his life about
but my thing with john was that
alongside all of those all of those
flaws he let it all hang out didn't he
just yeah
i'm a flawed character this is me yeah
you know yeah great question
great just to touch on the beatles
doing the loader rings which i think
would have been such a fun movie um
if they had to play everyone the four of
them had to
you know populate the whole of lord of
the
rings
then mary and pippin for me would be
uh george and ringo i would think i
think that's a good shout out
um yeah good great
another voicemail from a human
hey guys so first of all thank you so
much for doing this uh you guys are
great and i've never been so excited for
a new podcast so
just want to thank you guys right off
the bat so my question is of course
about the trilogy and
i had a quick question about casting so
i think most people can agree that lord
of the rings was perfectly casted like
everyone fit their role perfectly
so i was wondering kind of how you guys
felt going into the movie did you read
for any other characters
and also how did you feel with that
responsibility to kind of embody those
roles thanks again guys
this is what happens a lot in castings
and people don't
tend to know about this too much that
are outside of the business but what
what can happen a lot and certainly what
happened for me in lord of the rings
is you'll read for a generic role
initially and then they'll start to
figure out where they might be able to
place you
so for lord of the rings from my side of
things
there was a generic hobbit read
which was frodo greeting gandalf
at the door and saying you know you're
late and
you know it's great to see you again and
they come in and they have the
conversation to see if you could be
hobbity
and then from then on they start to
think well okay we've we've got an idea
for frodo but that person had some
hobbit elements so maybe they can play
this character in this character same
for me in which is another example
lost there was only when i went in to uh
see those guys on lost there was only
two reeds one was the scene with kate
that all the ladies read
and one was the scene with sawyer that
all the guys read so a lot of people
said oh you read for sawyer initially
not really but you're ready yeah to see
if you can fit into the world have you
had that experience outside of rings
um yeah well the rings thing for me
i read a sort of generic scene as well i
suppose but
it was more like what would have been
sam seen
right and looking through the window and
all dropping eaves
yeah that sort of thing it was a scene
like that but they did say
it was pippin at the time um
but other jobs yeah there's been where
they just want to see you do
something yeah and then everybody's so
secretive sometimes on jobs
they don't want to actually give you a
scene so they they make up a
a bad scene yeah and just we do a thing
as well don't we
we watch sometimes we watch a tv show or
something
and somebody really nails a speech
and we go do you think that was the
addition that was the idea because i've
done more work on that than
anything else in it yeah yeah for sure
you can always spot that as an actor
what their audition scene was it's
usually either a monologue or or a scene
with only one other character and kind
of an emotional yeah
yeah because just to touch upon that i
think if i remember rightly
orlando read for faramir and lots of
people were just
initially reading for a kind of generic
human-y role
yeah yeah and then they thought oh
orlando he looks good maybe he's more
elven and then he came in and did that
so i think that answers your question
thanks thank you very much
hi this is kenny from liverpool and yes
i am a fan of the six-time
european champions liverpool football
club
but my question is for billy i was just
wondering if you
are a fan of bell and sebastian i know
they're from scotland
um like yourself and i was just
wondering whether you have a favorite
song
or a favorite album and if you've ever
played with them
or any stories like that really enjoy
the podcast
stay safe bye
thank you can you do a scout's accent no
can you
yeah i think that's right i think it's
quite easy what i do with scouse accents
is
just keep a little bit more spit
in the back of me throat so it just
becomes kind of like you
like grabbing on this on the spit you
know that's good
thanks yeah belle and sebastian you love
him i do i love bill and sebastian i
like
um a lot of glasgow music i feel like um
i understand where it comes from and uh
there's a lot of different sort of
genres obviously but i think berlin
sebastian
really caught something in
in music that no one else really had
uh i've never played with them um but i
do
think they're brilliant and when you say
caught something you mean off the mics
no i mean like their type of music just
really feels like a type of glasgow that
i
i really think that they they they
nailed something in their music that i
think is brilliant i think they're great
but my wife was very upset
when she found out that belle and
sebastian weren't a
couple yeah because she didn't like that
she had asked you years later so
is that belle singing is that bell or
sebastian i'm like no
i think that's from a french cartoon or
something the boy with the arab strap
i remember us having on heavy rotation
in new zealand
great stuff great and years later we did
uh
i did uh um a sitcom in
glasgow called empty and i really pushed
for bill and sebastian to
to be the the theme song for i can't
even remember what song i was talking
about then
uh but we went a different way and i was
i was kind of upset
because i felt like that really this
says glasgow and it's
it was quirky and uh i really uh
yeah i love bill and sebastian great uh
question there from scouser
oh william thank you that is that it for
voicemails that's it for voicemail said
but now we have questions now here's
another question
from matt w he wanted to stay uh
slightly anonymous in new jersey said hi
guys i love the podcast
and what you're doing with it thanks
with the pandemic what is the quarantine
habit that you're most proud of to have
got into
or what quarantine habit surprised you
the most
when i'm not under quarantine and
there's no pandemic i like going to like
a gym
you know lifting some weight pumping it
up yeah doing a class or something
and i found myself working out at home
and i've quite enjoyed that though
i don't even know if i'll go back to a
gym now same i quite like
stretching my legs there maybe lift a
couple of things
you've got a bike haven't you got a
peloton bike i'll go
health a leather on that thing sweat
pouring off me
dom yeah sometimes i make noise
how's the knees by the way because these
are bikes are very good for knees
yeah yeah that will keep them lubricated
and you've you've been uh instructed by
your doctor to to pump your ass up
matt i've got i've got to use my my butt
more when i walk upstairs squats squats
are good
what squats are very good dom lunges
side lunges just keeping myself moving
keeping active
can i make a suggestion carry on have
your wife make you a
really really tasty cheese sandwich and
then
when you go for it and have a step take
a couple of steps back and you'll you
will
go inadvertently lunge and then step
back and then lunge
but have a do that most evenings and you
you watch the difference in your ass
what's your favorite cheese you've only
got three seconds to answer cabinzola
well done it's a german cheese behaving
like an italian blue
oh wait what was the quest oh for me
well how about you most get into them
well i'm a big i'm a big gardener i do
like to garden and in the last
year my gardening went to a different
level
which was you know i had this is the
first time ever in my entire life that i
spent
a year and a half in my house in la so i
was able to plan things in my garden
that might take
six months or nine months to grow
instead of
trying to get things to grow overnight
because i might be
leaving my house to go you've got to
give it time okay
the garden project that i did on my hill
was pretty fantastic
what quarantine habit surprised you the
most
um i mean the fact that we're still
playing league of legends is quite
surprising
is that surprising i didn't think i
would play it's been a solid year of
playing
and we're still absolute trash and we
don't have elijah on the team yet
no right next question hang on this is
from adam
jellycat gee and she says hey john and
billy
my name is angel and i live in the
beautiful northern part of michigan
personal question for the both of you
what brings you the most
peace or makes you the happiest is it a
place
a song a person and she thanks us for
her answers
angel even that question made me feel
quite peaceful it's quite nice isn't it
what if you had to what do people say
michigan
or michigan i think michigan yeah
what most people would say what shape is
michigan
do you know no most people say a hand
so whenever anyone talks about where
they come from in michigan they say
oh i'm near the pinky or i'm right here
near the wedding ring right is it it's
like the palm of a hand
yeah right okay so there you go there's
a piece of information for you
lovely bills uh what brings you the most
peace
well i mean i just answered a question
about my garden being in my garden for a
couple of hours looking at my
my phone and realizing that two hours
went by just
pottering around in my garden has been
amazing i'm on this
21 day specific
meditation right now which is and this
is going to
sound a little flowery and strange to
some people
who knows if it works or who knows if it
doesn't but this is a
chakra meditation lovely so it's 21 days
three days working on each specific
chakra nice and i had a meditation the
day before yesterday which is always my
favorite type of meditation
i'm not sure if if you've had this i'm
sure you have
where you have this kind of almost like
gyroscope
moving kind of uh sensation so i'm sat
for kind of 15 minutes meditating
and suddenly i have the sensation that
i'm spinning in space
upside down anti-clockwise clockwise
round and about whilst also meditating
have you had that sensation
yeah i think i probably have quite
nicely
very nice but what's what's really
intriguing about it is if
for me at least if i get interested or
like oh this is really fun
it disappears yeah so i have to find
myself saying i accept this this is
great and not get too impressed about it
i think that's very good though what
about you um
like you but in a kind of different way
but like in a garden or a park
putting things in a perspective i think
brings me the most peace
so looking at you know a bird flying
past
and then looking down and there's 400
ants and
there's a bee and and i just think god
you're actually such a small part of
everything that's going on yeah
that brings me happiness and peace when
i feel like
just when you feel unimportant
that's my that's what insignificant
yeah yeah i find out but in balance with
everything
yeah just looking and just thinking you
know look at all those ants and
they don't even know i exist yeah and
then it's a big sky
up there and the size of the universe
yeah
i like that i say that to people a lot
when people ask me questions on
on social media about concerns about a
spider in their bathroom
or or a wasp near their back door or
something i always say to them
first thing to keep in mind is this
animal has no concept of you whatsoever
yeah does not know that you're there
does not know that you're there to
bother it is not out to get you
and that's a little perspective thing
right yeah and i think i said to a few
weeks ago this is something that i've
been
interested to kind of explore one of my
favorite
feelings now in my brain sounds so silly
but it's true
is doing something and just
realizing what i'm going to do next
they'll tell you that no
so i'll be gardening whatever and i'll
think okay
got about 20 minutes left of gardening
here so i'll kind of grab
grab the shovel and the trowel and start
to tidy up get my gardening gloves
and as i'm doing that the last little
bit of pottery i think
okay what should i do next and i think
i'll cook lunch or i'll i'll watch
netflix or something like
that feeling of doing something and
knowing what is next in the agenda
is one of my favorite feelings of
tranquility i like that yeah i'm gonna
do that yeah
that's good oh and we've also got some
apple reviews aged what i'll read this
one bill yeah here we go
amy's mama emmy's mama says
i especially loved the conversation with
elijah about parenting
especially parenting in a pandemic
because with an eight-month-year-old my
eight-month-old myself
it was refreshing to hear authentic
thoughts
i've never ever heard a podcast before
this one and i'm glad i chose this one
to be the first
emmy's mama emmy's eight months old
thanks emmy's mama you know i've noticed
a lot of people have got in touch with
me saying
this is the first time that i've
actually subscribed and started to
consistently listen to podcasts because
of the podcast that you do with bills so
welcome to the podcast
world guys be sure to leave a review for
us obviously take a screen grab before
you submit and tag us
at the friendship onion and maybe you'll
feature on our stories
and dom eat the world billy do you know
what time it is
it's what dominic it's time for billy
and dummy in the world
my favorite part of the day my favorite
part of the day too
it's exciting today dom now john our
illustrious producer is bringing in
a beverage for us hiya john
you look very beautiful today i'm
wearing all great
i love it john's wearing old gray he's
bro he's brought us a pint
glass each and some oat milk and a knife
normal milk cow milk and what we're
featuring today
oh is rhode island coffee syrup
john is now exiting the room but he's
going to talk us through
what we do here this is i'll read this
out to you guys all right
in rhode island you can find this in a
convenience or grocery store much like
chocolate milk but to enjoy elsewhere in
the country you need to order the secret
ingredients coffee syrup and whole milk
to mix it yourself so this is kind of
like a
a chocolate milk thing but it's got a
coffee
taste so hold on i wonder if i can get
this right here john
so in rhode island you can buy this
ready-made but only in rhode island
is is there a company that makes it or
do like
stores make it autocrat autocrat
is the premier brand of
coffee syrup which you use to make
coffee milk
but can you buy it actually as coffee
milk in rhode island
i believe so yeah so or if you basically
if you go to coffee shops that they have
it like pre-made
like you would find mochas or something
out here ah
okay so you go here like a corner store
and the guys
made it in the store you don't buy it in
a
bottle pre-made oh you can buy it i
think it's like it's at you know
it's it's uh you know almost like a blue
bottle coffee you know where you can
like buy pre-made
with all the ingredients mixed in i
believe that's out there or you just buy
the syrup
or you just get it made at a coffee shop
i'll tell you how you make it
thank you john uh just one thing yeah
two tablespoons
into one cup of milk is the reason
you've made that slightly difficult for
us
because rather than giving us a
tablespoon john you've given us a knife
two knives two tablespoons i think is
probably
13 knives well it depends the full
length of the knife or just from the
serrated
i'm just going to give it a couple of
big squirts yeah give that a good squat
there's one there's two there you go
you've done well then pass that over to
you william two metered to my left
ah give that some it's heavier than you
would think isn't it
it's heavy i don't think there's any
caffeine
in the coffee syrup are you sure and i
wouldn't necessarily
describe it as a i'm going to call that
one healthy dish hold on
can you hear this you can't hear a thing
it's completely silent i am now pouring
oat milk
into this uh glass vessel
i am pouring uh cow's milk
lovely uh lovely hue that's not the name
of our new producer lovely hue i mean
the color
um well it's coffee colored isn't it
really yeah
one cup of cool all right okay give that
a stir
if it were me i would add a little ice
cube well because i like an icy coffee
well you can have everything should we
read a little bit more about this stuff
so obviously very popular in rhode
island first introduced to rhode
islanders
in the early 1920s coffee milk became so
popular
it was designated the official state
drink
of rhode island in 1993. no
dominic mysterious as it may be to
outsiders
coffee milk is a pretty obvious leap for
anyone who's had a glass of strawberry
or chocolate milk
it's a sugary syrup commonly made from
instant coffee
mixed with sugar and corn syrup it's
bottle and added
a few spoonfuls at a time to a glass of
milk then stirred
and enjoyed it says here which is quite
concerning originally marketed at
children oh yes coffee drink virgin as a
way to get them to drink their milk and
also
coffee today the syrup is a favorite of
both young and old and
transplanted rhode islanders take to the
web
to keep their kitchen stuck oh you can
only get it from all
so the worldwide internet to everyone in
in rhode island
cheers cheers chinchin all the best
right make sure you masticate
mastication is very important
well that is a absolutely and i'll tell
you something dom
i tell you it would make that even
better right now
if you get this first guess what i would
put in there to make that better
something you would put in the coffee
drink to make it better
another flavor
i can almost taste it in it another
flavor
yeah is it
is it honey that went down the wrong way
there a little malteser
hey was it honey because it's very sweet
it's very sweet but you know what i'd
put in and it would sweeten it even more
you're ready done oh nutella no
sorry good guess marmite no
condensed milk oh my god ah can you
imagine it with condensed milk
yeah it would be nice close your eyes
and then have a sip of it just sip it
through your lips and think of condensed
milk
it would be so sweet it's already sweet
and you know how if you have something
really sweet your your bum hole gets
itchy yeah it does
what is that i don't know what that is
but if i eat too
much sweets or as they're known in the
united states
candy the whole yeah of my posterior
gets itchy itchy effort
where sometimes i might have to just um
let's say create some space
and if anyone knows where my bum hole
might get you after sweets
maybe a medical student out there or our
fully fledged doctor
yeah yeah could you please write in or
leave a
voicemail and tell us why his bum hole
would get at you after sweets
hey there's a few things that happened
with me was like apples make my cheeks
sweat
true story if i give us another one fine
well
salt some salt and vinegar crisps make
my make my cheeks
sweat um i think that's it
that's not bad that um i'm gonna have
another drink of this can we
can we read out the ingredients of the
coffee syrup because
i wouldn't describe it as a healthy dish
well let me just tell you what's in it
it's on beverage
and as you know and for all the
listeners whenever you read out um
or you're having a read at the
ingredients of anything the first thing
is the thing that's mainly in it yeah
and then slowly
as the percentages go down you go down
the list
right which is why in britain they had
to stop
calling um steak and kidney pies taking
kidney pies because there was much more
kidney than there was steak so do they
call it kidney and steak paint i think
they do but
give me the first one dom you'll get it
right uh
high fructose corn syrup on the nose
i've nailed it second
corn syrup they need double the corn
syrup yeah but one part of it is not
high fructose
i don't know why you would need double
corn syrup
i mean that is sweet isn't it sweet then
you've got
coffee extract caramel color
potassium sorbate and it's got sulfates
i mean nothing in that is healthy
but it's tasty i like the taste of it
dom
and it's quite moorish for me i should
give him some scores
it should be colder it should be colder
there should have been some ice in there
but
he can't catch a break with john he's
treating us like pigs
honestly it's as if he doesn't care um
should we give it some scores yeah
please
it's craziness i always forget the
categories taste
aesthetics how it looks and how useful
is it
okay first taste out of ten
you can have points in there i'm giving
it a
i'm giving it a three oh a three out of
three it's just it's not done
it's not it's not his thing it's not
your thing
a big glass of milk with some sugary
coffee but there's no caffeine in the
coffee
why why there's no caffeine in it no
there's no caffeine oh that's that's
why would you drink it wait a minute
john's about to say something
nope i think he's just uh he just moved
there just making sure that i think
there is caffeine
oh hold on that could change the
usefulness yeah that could
so you you keep looking at that says
slightly caffeinated syrup
while i do this hold on i'm going to say
for taste
because i quite like the taste but
i know what you mean it's a little bit
oh that's a bit sweet for me
very sweet i'm going to give it a sex
there you have tom honestly who would
like this is my father because he has
a sweet tooth he loves condensed milk
and there's a bit of a condensate milk
vibe to that
and he likes a coffee so i think my dad
would like that do you know what i'd
like to do with your dad one day go on
just sit down in front of tv maybe with
a football on or something
and we'll just share a big tin of
condensed milk
two spoons we'll just take the top off
and we'll just sit there i'd love that
i would love that he would love that um
okay oh hold on john oh john
so it has 95 milligrams of caffeine
which is about
uh you need to drink seven cups of
coffee
to have oh sorry you need to drink seven
cups of coffee milk to get the same as
one cup of coffee
oh no it's not enough caffeine so it has
a seventh of the normal amount of coffee
of a normal cup of coffee so imagine
if you will a cup of coffee was
all the dwarfs and sleeping beauty
yeah this would just be sleepy right
right got it so aesthetics can we just
hold up the bottle i quite like the look
of the bottle actually
like a dark not quite well
it's black it's what a weight is why is
it so heavy yeah it's quite
viscous wait what you're thinking from
an aesthetics point of view i like the
yellow and the
and the red and the black why does it
get a chicken i'm not sure why it's got
a chicken on it is it
because it wakes up early in the morning
i'm gonna give the aesthetics
a 7.8 very good john because when i look
at that
it doesn't do much for me i don't like
the check in i'm giving it a 3.
oh this is going to be the lowest score
up to now and then usefulness
i mean what would you put it in if you
didn't put it in milk
some sort of milk i'm guessing maybe the
people of rhode island have
created some sort of puddings or
desserts with it like a coffee flavored
cake
or a you know like maybe a tiramisu with
a little bit of that in there but it's
not very flexible is it it's kind of
drink
coffee syrup and that's it hold on dom
you're gone
i've just looked there it's not just
autocrat who makes us like take for
instance
dave's coffee who won the 2013 yankee
magazine editor's choose
choice food awards they have their own
which is all natural scallops philips
syllabs so there's obviously some
alcohol in there
and they have an original vanilla
and marker flavors and there's no
artificial colors
sweeteners are high fructose corn syrup
in there what do you think of that
well i think we should have had dave's
coffee why didn't we have the dips
why didn't we try both of them john's
trying to poison us
um so in terms of what is it flexibility
no
i i how useful is how useful is it
i'm giving that a one it give out one
it's not
useful is it wow you're about
a one almost feels like you can't even
drink it
give me tell me something else you can
do apart from make coffee milk with that
you know what you could put put that on
top of some nice vanilla ice cream
and you'll be good to go and you can
also put
women at john's got an idea i'm saying
just uh scroll down a bit there's one
more
scroll down a bit there dom and i'll and
you can tell us exactly
look look at that well it says here do
you want your
coffee milk cold and creamy just add
some vanilla ice cream and blend the
whole thing together
into a coffee cabinet that's a frappe to
other new englanders
and a milkshake to those that are really
from away
what doesn't make any sense really from
away
john you've scoped us again you know
i'll read anything off a computer screen
he's made me read a nonsensical sentence
milkshake to those that are really
anyway they're saying that you can add
vanilla milkshake to it to make it into
a kind of
ice cream drink but still not very
flexible
you're probably right i'll give it a
four sorry rhode islanders
it's it's not our favorite but i'm still
drunk the whole thing
i didn't i only drank half i found it
very sickly we're moving on
[Music]
right dom before we finish someone sent
and
a lovely tune for is it funky
and this is from larissa marcotti
would you say marcotti or marcotti why
not larissa marcotti from
love land california and this is the
wailing jenny's long time traveler right
let's have a listen listen to this
your springs of joy are
dry my soul
now seeks another home
a brighter world
i mean is it funky
i think we should get to that in a
second because i think there's a very
clear answer as to whether it's funky or
not but it was quite
haunting and beautiful it could almost
fit
in middle earth you could imagine maybe
yeah some
lovely ladies from gondor or rohan
singing that on a mountaintop
type thing or marion pippin haydn
somewhere in the show
as as the elves walk past
[Music]
i don't think it's funky tom no but it
was brilliant no
it reminded me of the scottish guy who
did a thing on tick-tock where he sang
like a a sea shanty
and then he asked he didn't even ask
people but everybody joined in
and people did base harmony
human voices mixing together i like that
too but on a scale of brahms
no funk to prince funkadelic
what are you gonna score i mean to be
honest we have to put it there
in the way of a you know
maybe some sort of choir
is it allan jones well you could put it
there as an alert jones
i say winnifred school quiet i went to
saint winnipes when i was a kid
no you didn't i did i went to school at
st went in front you did not
i absolutely did in fact my cousins
sang in the choir that did grandma
we love you they're on top of the pops
they wear usually you're on top of the
pot
you went in that school i went to saint
winifred's rc
primary school you should have told me
on
sister aquinas and sister margarita um
ah
i'm gonna say on a scale of brahms to
prince
i'm gonna say schubert not to be
confused with sherbet
it was not funky but it was wonderful
i'm gonna go home and uh get hold of
that i'm gonna look up the wheel and
jenny's because that was brilliant
that's it we're done with the show do
you know what we've gone way over
again because there's way too much of
you and me but we just can't stop can we
we can't stop talking and then when
people send us things we want to talk
about it i enjoyed it
guys it's been fantastic make sure you
get in touch with us
cass no the friendship on your
netcastmedia.com
that's cast with a kicking k
and you can also leave a voicemail of
course
but where would you leave that door well
it's somewhere around here
www dot speak pipe
forward slash the friendship onion i've
ruined it no you've done good
it's it's www dot
speak pipe dot com forward slash
this friendship onion nice one and
there's obviously the friendship onion
on
instagram there's the friendship onion
on youtube
leave us all your comments let us know
what you want us to get in touch if
you've got food or beverages that you
want us to eat
songs that you want to ask if they're
funky or not
leave messages please don't forget to
subscribe please guys
please we want to remain at number one
don't forget to rate
and review very important and when you
do review
take a screenshot tag us in it we'll
stick it on instagram i will read it out
here
we'll see you next week i love that
toodles